welcome back everybody we end Today's
Show with new developments in the death
of 29 year old Tyree Nichols on Monday
his family held a press conference after
being shown the horrific police
encounter with their son through body
cam footage Antonio romanucci an
attorney for the victim's family
described the police encounter as a
quote non-stop beating for three minutes
and Nichols is a quote human pinata
Nichols died three days after his
confrontation with police on January 10.
he was pulled over for alleged reckless
driving and police say that Nichols ran
before being taken into custody after
complaining of shortness of breath
Nichols was taken to the hospital in
critical condition so far five
responding officers have been fired and
two members of the fire department have
been suspended the extent of his
injuries and the official cause of death
haven't been revealed and the body cam
footage of the arrest is expected to be
released in the coming days as the
investigation leaves many details still
in the dark prominent civil rights
attorney Ben Crump shed a positive light
on Nichols life
not Tyree
not Tyree I mean he was a good young man
a good young man everybody from FedEx
his co-workers all his skateboarding
Community all the people who were in
photography class with him
um I mean this was a good kid
his mother said
the things that stood out to her about
what was his focus in life
skateboarding and we'll share with you
video of how good of a skateboarder he
was
photography
and computers
and most importantly
being a father he loved his son
everything he was trying to do was to
better himself as a father for his
four-year-old son
so Terry the video hasn't been released
to the public but based on the current
reports you think there's enough
evidence to file murder charges against
the five police officers yes I do Jesse
I think there's enough here first of all
he was stopped but he ran away and then
he was confronted but it turns out you
know there was a use of a stun gun and
he also was also being held five
individuals against one individual and
these five police officers they have all
been on the force for over 20 years
they're now all fired and the police
department itself said that it was
excessive force and they didn't provide
any sort of medical care I think those
facts are enough facts to charge I don't
think it'll be first degree murder that
they'll get a conviction for first
degree here is making sure that it's
premeditated and that it's intentional I
don't know if they'll be able to show
that but second-degree murder and
certainly manslaughter I think that
would be to demonstrate here Brian some
of the officers they were part of the
organized crime unit why is that
important why does that stand out
there's a few things Jesse organized
crimes Like Jesse said these people were
on the force for 20 years they're
looking for the big crime the the drug
dealers the the gangsters The Killers
the shooters all of those so if they're
looking and stopping someone for a
traffic infraction that's what they
believe is happening and with the type
of crime that they're used to dealing
with is the big crime if else to use an
analogy this is like using a
sledgehammer to put in a thumbtack is it
possible that I can do it without
destroying the wall yeah I have to be
very very careful but like you see here
they brought a sledgehammer to a
thumbtack and they just beat the Wall
they destroyed everything and I know
it's a poor analogy to use when you're
talking about someone who died but
that's what I see in these cases with
organized crime unit going after small
cases people are terrified of them
because of the force that they exert and
the force they're used to exerting
against people so when people like Tyree
Nichols get into their pathway they
don't often take the soft approach they
take the hard approach and I think
that's what stuck out to me when I heard
that some of them were from the
organized crime unit that's a good point
and it's going to be interesting to see
what a possible defense will be for
whatever resulting in Brian Terry thank
you both so much everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on Long crime
daily we'll see you next as we discuss
Justice in America